[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen für den sport an meiner seite
unsere großen themen heute neue regeln
bei der einreise wer nicht geimpft oder
genesen ist muss an der grenze einen
test vorzeigen kritik am wahlkampf der
union csu-chef söder fordert im
zdf-sommerinterview mehr tempo und
historischer triumph alexanders wäre
holt als erster deutscher tennisspieler
einzel gold bei olympia
egal ob sie mit dem auto dem flugzeug
oder der bahn nach deutschland einreisen
zb nach einem urlaub ist gelten ab heute
neue chor ohne regeln und die seen im
einzelnen so aus alle ab zwölf jahren
müssen nun eine impfung oder eine
genesung nachweisen oder ein
testergebnis vorlegen
ein schnelltest darf maximal 48 stunden
alt sein
ein pcr-test 72 stunden strengere regeln
gelten weiterhin für hochrisiko und
virusvarianten gebiete patricia schäfer
und brigitte sei berichten
seit mitternacht wird die neue test
pflicht für einreisende kontrolliert
stichprobenartig das heißt die polizei
winkt einzelne fahrzeuge hinaus so wie
hier an der grenze zu den niederlanden
bei bad bentheim
ich muss auf den vollen quarantäne
aufgrund einer impfung
wir wollten eigentlich auf nummer sicher
gehen in amsterdam uns da direkt testen
lassen weil das auch irgendwie in den
flug mit drinstand aber als aus dem
flughafen rausgekommen sind ja hat sich
halt niemand der nach deutschland müsse
testen lassen zurückgeschickt wird aber
niemand in diesem fall folgt eine
meldung ans gesundheitsamt und zehn tage
quarantäne
[Musik]
am anderen ende der republik die
inntalautobahn kontrollstelle
kiefersfelden an der grenze zu
österreich viele wurden im urlaub von
der neuen testpflicht überrascht wir
sind vor 14 tagen in italien gefahren da
hieß es
gibt's noch keine tests nicht sag ich
jetzt mal für deutschland und jetzt das
seit mittwoch gab's ja hin und her sagt
zur sicherheit noch mal eins gemacht
dass wir keine probleme haben die kosten
für die tests im ausland muss man selbst
tragen
die reisenden sind alle sehr gut
vorbereitet und seit mitternacht gab es
bisher überhaupt keine beanstandungen
weil alle ihre tests genesenen oder
geimpften nachweise dabei hatten auch
wer mit bahn oder schiff einreist muss
mit den neuen corona kontrollen rechnen
am kieler hafen trifft das urlaubs
rückkehrer aus schweden
aber der polizist hatte gemeint heute
muss noch nicht so ganz streng ausgelegt
doch das kann noch kommen
bundesinnenminister seehofer hat
engmaschige kontrollen angekündigt und
bußgelder
alle 12 bis 17 jährigen sollen die
möglichkeit bekommen sich impfen zu
lassen das sieht ein vorschlag des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums vor
die gesundheitsministerin und minister
der länder wollen dass offenbar morgen
bei ihrer konferenz beschließen alle
bundesländer sollen dann in den
impfzentren impfung für kinder und
jugendliche anbieten und die pandemie
auch großes thema im zdf sommerinterview
mit dem csu parteichef und bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten markus söder
die union musste den umfragen der
zuletzt federn lassen im
zdf-politbarometer kommt sie nur noch
auf 28 prozent
söder selbst sieht sich im wahlkampf als
antreiber mathis feldhoff berichtet es
ist oft der heimische platz das eigene
stadion das sicherheit gibt dem csu chef
offenbar die sicherheit seiner attacken
der letzten tage fortzusetzen
seit wochen treibt markus söder armin
laschet vor sich her auch heute im zdf
laschet hat sie sich zuletzt gegen druck
auf impfwillige ausgesprochen so dagegen
will den druck und setzt die debatte
fort wenn man zweimal geimpft ist dann
stellt man kaum mehr eine gefahr für
sich und andere war und deswegen macht
es dann sind diese rechte wieder
herzustellen alles andere ist ein
eingriff in die in die
verfassungsmäßigen rechte seit wochen
bei harken und die chefs der unions
parteien oder treibt um der falsche
kandidat der behäbige wahlkampf würde
die gesamte union in die niederlage
ziehen
meine sorge ist dass das ganze so jetzt
dahin plätschert und das am ende weil
man nicht genügend uns engagieren dann
am ende zwei ausgleichsmandaten hier ein
überhangmandat dort da gibt's plötzlich
eine mehrheit für eine ampel
markus söder kann kaum verhehlen dass er
sich immer noch für den besseren hält
auch wenn er ständig betont dass er mit
seiner gescheiterten kandidatur
abgeschlossen habe
ich bin der antreiber wenn sie das
anschauen ob testpflicht vorgeschlagen
kommt wahrscheinlich bei corona test
nicht mehr kostenlos vorgeschlagen
wahrscheinlich kommt wir brauchen
einfach mehr tempo und power
die botschaft an den eigenen kandidaten
ist klar
mit markus söder und seinen einwürfen
von der außenlinie wird man rechnen
müssen und das gesamte sommerinterview
mit dem csu-parteichef sehen sie im
anschluss an diese sendung oder
jederzeit in unserer mediathek oder der
zd erfreute m
trotz verbots haben sich in berlin
mehrere tausend menschen zu einer
demonstration der sogenannten querdenker
versammelt darunter viele corona leugner
ihr protest richtet sich vor allem gegen
die maßnahmen in der pandemie
nach polizeiangaben versuchten einige
demonstranten absperrungen zu
durchbrechen
die veranstaltung wurde aufgelöst und
hunderte personen festgenommen noch
immer werden in den hochwassergebieten
in rheinland-pfalz 59 menschen vermisst
insgesamt sind dort und in nordrhein
westfalen bisher 182 menschen tot
geborgen worden
die trauer um die verstorbenen und der
shop sind groß wie besonders schwer es
ist damit inmitten der zerstörungen
umzugehen darüber berichtet beach area
jeden tag seit dem hochwasser sucht
pastor heiko mark watson das gespräch zu
anwohnern in und um bad neuenahr
ahrweiler
es sind unterhaltungen über die große
zerstörung den verlust des eigenen
zuhauses und über menschen die ich hier
in der gegend ums leben kamen
es gibt leider auch so tragische
geschichten
von leuten die erzählen dass die
nachbarn sich stundenlang an der
hauswand irgendwo festgeklammert haben
und die nachbarn sie versucht haben mit
luftmatratzen und so zu retten
damit ihr irgendwie überleben aber
leider dann mit ansehen mussten wie die
nachbarn von der von der flutwelle
weggespült worden sind fast immer gehe
er auf die menschen zu sagt marc warzen
für tiefer gehende gespräche bliebe
vielen bei all dem aufräumen keine zeit
dabei gibt es eine menge redebedarf bei
betroffenen und helfern gleichermaßen
zwar die ersten tage war es schwer aber
mittlerweile kann man es besser
verarbeiten auch viele friedhöfe im
aartal wurden durch das hochwasser
zerstört wie hier in altena gewohnte
treffer orte sind nicht nutzbar
auch dafür braucht es lösungen
angehörige müssen ihre toten in
nachbarorten bestatten lassen und auch
im hinterkopf einfach noch mal die frage
zu haben ob auch eine umbettung zu einem
späteren zeitpunkt eine möglichkeit ist
brender friedhof in altena wieder
hergerichtet ist der wiederaufbau nach
dem hochwasser eine gewaltige aufgabe
dazu die herausforderung in all dem
chaos den angemessenen raum zu finden
für die verarbeitung von tod und trauer
in der türkei kämpfen tausende
einsatzkräfte den fünften tag in folge
gegen die schweren waldbrände in der
nacht mussten in der ferienregion bodrum
mehrere dörfer evakuiert werden
die menschen wurden mit booten über das
meer in sicherheit gebracht und es
brennt auch in den provinzen anteil
lukla mindestens acht menschen sind
bislang ums leben gekommen und wir
kommen zurück pia und damit zu norbert
und zum historisch nachfolge von
alexander schweres im tennis-finale die
erste deutsche goldmedaille im herren
einzel überhaupt und was für ein
souveräner sieg des hamburgers sein
gegner der rustikalen razzano chancenlos
wäre es siegte nach nur einer stunde und
19 minuten mit 6 3 6 2 1 und schreibt
olympia geschichte
diese momente der glückseligkeit des
stolzes und der erleichterung bilden
einen absoluten höhepunkt im leben des
24 jahre alten alexander zverev ab das
habe ich eine goldmedaille um 1 und mein
nacken
es ist das sind gefühle die ich in
meinem leben noch nicht nicht
beschreiben kann
es wäre als finalgegner der russe karin
hahn auf konnte die letzten beiden
begegnungen deutlich für sich
entscheiden
umso erstaunlicher seine totale
chancenlosigkeit angesichts eines
gegners der heute zwei hoch überlegene
sätze lang tennis wie von einem anderen
stern spielte es ist etwas haben wir
nicht mehr träumen kann die goldmedaille
ist nicht nur für dich sondern für das
ganze land und ich habe nicht eine
sekunde auf dem platz verbracht für mich
zu spielen ich habe für ganz deutschland
gespielt
olympisches gold für alexander zverev an
einem tag an dem sich der hamburger tief
in die herzen der deutschen sportfans
gespielt hat und aufs podest schafft es
heute auch doppel weltmeister florian
wellbrock im 1500 m freistil finale
holte er bronze und damit die erste
männer medaille für die deutschen
beckenschwimmer seit 21 jahren
ja und dann gab es auch noch eine
faustdicke überraschung beim 100 meter
finale der männer
der italiener lärmend marcel jacob's
holt die goldmedaille in 9,80 sekunden
so sieht ein fassungsloser olympiasieger
aus marcel jacob's holt gold über 100
meter der italiener zweiter von rechts
als einzige europäer noch dabei nach 40
50 metern kommt der richtig ins rollen
und kann den topspeed bis zum ende
halten
marcel kopp schuld mit nachträglich
korrigieren 9,8 sekunden das erste
europäische 100 meter gold seit 1992
der 26 jährige der am gardasee lebt
verbessert damit auch den europarekord
silber geht an fett curly usa der
kanadier andre die gras holt bronze aber
der nachfolger von usain bolt heißt la
marcel jacob's und olympischen sport wir
bei uns im heute journal
dagegen hat und wir blicken noch auf die
wetter aussichten für morgen es gibt
eine sonne wolken mix und vor allem in
der mitte und im südwesten schauer und
gewitter die temperatur steigt auf 17
bis 22 grad
das heute journal sehen sie um 21 45 mit
claus kleber morgen begrüßt sie an
dieser stelle hier christian sievers und
jetzt geht es direkt weiter mit dem zdf
sommerinterview machen wir es gut